[Music]
thank you so much joining me
this is my first question really when do
you know you've got a story
when do you take the thing that's in
your mind in your head and you start to
develop it in a serious way what's that
process like and
sometimes it's different for every book
so i can only really give you concrete
examples
and that with the blackwater lightship
say the novel i had something
and then on a fridge or something an
image of something
and then on a friday evening and i
remember it i went to a movie and had it
i had an
espresso before the movie which i
wouldn't normally do on you know in the
evening
so when i came home i was slightly wired
it was a friday evening and i was alone
and i just
simply the first sentence of the novel
came and i started to work
and i didn't expect it and uh
that's how that happened and sometimes
with a short story again you just get an
opening sentence and then you just work
you see you can't force it but once you
have the
beginning you must then force it you
must work
there's no point in saying i must wait
for inspiration to come for each
sentence or each section
once you get the opening you have as it
were a key
and you know you know as though you're
writing in a certain key
and you simply work within the tones
that the opening sentence has offered
you sometimes this looks this looks very
simple i mean the opening sentence of
the blackwater lightship
is as follows helen woke in the night
to the sound of manners whimpering well
that's not much
but actually it gives you a way in it's
a suggestion that this is a chamber
piece
that is probably for two instruments or
for solo piano
it's not a big orchestral opening you
know i've
got a novel coming out next year about
thomas mann
and i had all the work done and i sort
of knew what i wanted to do but i just
didn't have
the key i didn't know what i was how i
was going to start and i was in brazil
where thomas man's mother was born
and his mother was brazilian and
which gave him a sort of an exotic thing
which is terribly important in his
makeup
and um so there's a mixture of this
lubic merchant
his father with this woman who was born
in brazil his mother and um
so i'm standing at the house which is um
on the coast
and it's in an inlet and i'm with the um
australian
novelist richard flanagan and
the house is right on the water and
richard points out to me
and i have no idea whether this is true
or not it doesn't bother me that
in the southern hemisphere the stars are
lower
the sky is lower at night and the stars
are much more visible
and that you can in a house like that
with water so much water
you can actually read by the light of
the stars at night that starts hitting
against the water
and the water being all brightness of
course i thought this was the most
marvelous image i didn't stop to say
richard are you sure this is true
you know it's just something that thomas
man's mother tells but once once he said
it to me i was away i had the thing i
would start with
are there periods of sort of idler times
where you're waiting necessarily
for the inspiration to land
unfortunately i'm never idle
and i mean you know your job is to
finish the book
and that's the aim i mean you know so
you think well if i work today
it would be another step towards
finishing the book and so it becomes
work
you do it every day you find sometimes
that you get better at it
that the the sentences become more
fluent
or more sort of rhythmically
confident and uh but in between
and that what i do is i teach one
semester every year
so i'm i read a lot for if i'm teaching
a book i will always read the book the
days before
the class because i only work with
detail i don't have a theory
and um i find that very enriching and
and i'm not complaining about it
and i also write big long book reviews i
mean big
long book reviews and sometimes the big
book reviews
really are work and you get buried in
the business of um
whatever is your subject you know and
then so
i would have would have books piled up
to read or to consult and
i would be structuring the piece i would
be quite involved it'd be quite like
writing a novel
and the only difference is that you know
the editor becomes the person
almost like the entire reading public
where you only reaction you're ever
going to get from the editor they have
no interest in
whether you think the book is good or
bad so it's not like saying you know
this is a good review of this book it's
an essay around
the issues which the book raises and um
so it's um yeah yeah i become
really involved and with it and engaged
by it and it just
it keeps me out of harm's way how do you
find the balance between
teaching and then writing fiction the
other two terms of the year when when
you're not teaching
um i mean i think this this semester
this year
um at columbia um i taught a course on
ulysses for undergraduates
i was totally engaged with this um and
uh you know i did a lot of work every
week before the class and the classes
were busy
i think i hope by the end of the
semester the students
knew something they didn't know before
they were coming in i have a feeling
that
some of them won't forget just because
it was the book itself is so engaging
that you have that if you could just put
the energy and you get it
you get a great deal back from it and uh
that's that's how i work you were
detailed man and i've read
in preparing for this that you don't
necessarily see the importance of theory
i was wondering if you could
talk a bit more about it well i think
because i'm a novelist
um when i go into the classroom i go in
with the idea
that the book was at one point unwritten
and was written slowly and tentatively
by an
individual and that it comes from
a very enclosed and precise imagination
now once you accept this and not
everybody does
um the autonomy the willfulness
of the of the named author
then i can start getting under that
author's intentions
and look at the systems that author
worked with i think somebody else might
be able to come in
and look at the book in an entirely
different way
um arising from a set of theories about
literary value
um and um the the imagination itself
um it would simply be different i too
have a theory
and my theory is that the uh that the
imagination is autonomous what was that
process like well with teaching ulysses
over the course of the term what were
you looking for what caught your eye
oh i think what you were looking for was
with each episode
to make sure that it was understood how
autonomous again using the word
autonomous hard times each episode was
and how he
seemed he wanted to set up a style and
then exhaust the style
so that that he would replace it with
something else so he was he was
breathlessly going through whatever
tones were available to him breaking
each one as he went in other words he
was
as he as he left each house he burned
the house down
and moved on to another one so that in
something like cyclops
you're looking at an entirely different
system of narrative than you are saying
something like wandering rocks
and so therefore the point was as you
came to each episode to to actually look
what is this episode doing what stylist
do you think she would be looking for
what continuities from the previous
chapter
how are you so you would just go like
that and also sometimes
you you really need to gloss quite a lot
because
um there are things that are fascinating
for example
in cyclops at the whole like the whole
account of the execution of robert
emmett
you need to know who robert emmett was
but you need to know also what was the
emotion surrounding robert emmett
in dublin in 1904. i think euler says
at the moment um certain episodes
really do hit spots that um are in
dispute at the moment
for example there's a there's an episode
in the book where leopold
bloom masturbates on saturday mount
strand
is he's looking um under a woman's dress
and she seems to be
engaged with this but not wholly not his
gaze
is this um thing we know so well it's
the male case
and then that's something certainly the
students all
all of them are concerned about this and
wonder about creating images further
images of this and reading about it
and the other one is foreign in the
cersei episode in the brotherly cross
dresses and he actually becomes a woman
now again this is something that is a
burning issue at the moment
that in the classroom we have to look at
the text as both a living text meaning
we are reading it now
and as historical text meaning it was
published it's set in 1904
and was published in 1922 so we have to
look at it from
the gaze or the eyes of someone in 1922
as well as looking at it through our own
particular perspectives
so you know it isn't as though this is a
sort of a modernist masterpiece that we
have to sort of wade our way through
utterly bored by the by the images and
the
you know the um episodes that that it is
something that actually
really really begins to matter and um
also because stephen daedalus is a young
student in the book or he has been
he's he's a very young man that that
idea of somebody young wandering in a
city
but but there are many other things um
in the book that i think
interest a contemporary audience and
it's very
very exciting from my side presenting
this
to these um very enthusiastic students
for the first time in their lives
knowing that this is something that they
will remember you know as long as they
live
and it's an exciting idea what stands
out for you in what you've read as being
particularly influential for you as a
writer
i'm interested in a tradition that would
go say
from jane austen through to henry james
with perhaps
you know continuities in the 20th
century i'm interested in the idea of
how consciousness is rendered
how an individual is placed at the heart
of a book
and that often young woman but it could
be a young man
that the mind and the fate and the idea
of choice and chance
are all dealt with first of all as
unique experiences for a single
consciousness
and secondly someone living in a small
society
such as a family or a small community
and thirdly
whatever larger issues are affecting the
day
um but but the main thing is the single
face the single consciousness the single
soul as it were
and and you find this also in balzac and
you found in standard
um and you find it obviously in flow
this whole idea of
um as though you're taking your bearings
from rembrandt
or indeed from vermeer where you're
getting a single
face a single soul a single
consciousness a single set of um
feelings you're working with them so the
person
jane austen is often at her very best
when the person is alone
similarly in sort of like middle march
it's a fascinating panorama of a society
but but what really matters is when
dorothea is alone
what she does when she's alone how she
thinks and how the novel
um renders this this is a obviously the
big moment in in something like portrait
of a lady
where henry james finds it the most he
writes about the book
years later saying that they the chapter
where most happens is the chapter where
isabella's entirely alone
sitting by dying far through the night
thinking about things
and i think as a novelist i find that
those scenes are the hardest to write
and the most necessary and the ones you
have to put the most sort of
rhythmic energy into without putting too
much in
to keep the reader's mind or to keep hit
the reader's nervous system
so that the when the character is alone
that solitude has to become
energetic dynamic and dramatic in the
19th century
a novelist began to contemplate the
inner life
now it doesn't mean we don't have it
before we have it obviously in painting
we have it in shakespeare
but but i'm talking about the inner life
in a novel where the reader is reading
in silence
the reader is alone and this idea then
of looking at an individual spirit not
in relation to politics
or to history but in relation to
actually
their own feelings being enough for the
summons someone's destiny
or someone's relationship to choice or
chance being enough for a novel
without having to go into the whole
business of say the
the importance of a napoleonic war on
the novel or the importance of
corn laws or the importance of the topic
of the great reform act
these indecent george eliot are sort of
minor matters
compared to the larger question which is
that dorothea is facing her destiny
and we and and it's her life it's her
life within
that becomes dramatic now i think this
probably has
enormous political repercussions in some
way but i'm not interested in that
as much as i am in the idea of um
becoming involved in another
sensibility and the richer that
sensibility is the better as a reader
and finding that that sensibility yields
a great deal
what i mean is that that i'm that i'm
not just reading the novel for
entertainment
but i'm not reading it for instruction
either i'm
reading it for an emotional engagement
at the level of nervous system
where i'm actually feeling the thing
very deeply
the thing being what is happening to
this glittering
flickering consciousness within the
pages of this book
and the richer that this consciousness
is the more
um dynamic and the more contradictions
within the consciousness
particularly someone like madame bovary
say um or
indeed um with um something like um
dorothea or aries but archer or
um any of the women figures in them
in jane austen what's going through your
head when you're trying to
convince the reader that this is what
matters
i think sometimes that the next sentence
is a response
to the previous sentence and it may need
to be different in
tone to a different shape to it and it
may need to bring
things further but the most important
thing it needs to be true
this means it needs to be true to a
certain truth that you have set up
so that if someone is coming into a room
what they see the first thing they see
the first thing they notice
how they feel then so you do see
notice something else and make a
decision over where to move in the room
and then realize that might not have
been the right decision
and then try and move maybe further into
the shadows thus
to see further what was noticed earlier
on
so what you've built up by the end is a
picture of someone coming to a room
that um the the reader will know this
person
will want then will will i think if you
call this
if you call it the third person intimate
and if you say that the aim of it
is that very soon into a book maybe 30
pages in
and using third person singular he she
the reader starts to see the world
through that character's eyes
feel things through that character's
feelings
notice the world through that
character's ability to notice
and therefore the richer you you have
the characters
noticing skills the more developed
and the more detail you put in the more
you bring the reader in
so the reader in third person intimate
sees the world
through that um through the character's
eyes and therefore of course becomes
completely engaged with the character's
fate and worries about it
and also um i mean you you can obviously
do first person singular and some
writers do
some books some writers do and that
means you're hearing your voice
it is as though someone is whispering to
you or speaking to you or telling you
something but you're utterly alert to
their otherness to the fact that they're
another person with third person
intimate even though it should be more
remote
it oddly enough isn't that you become
engaged with the fate of the character
but
courtesy of of seeing the world
um slowly and i think it's a question of
accretion
that you build a detail you build a
detail and you make them true
or you make them seem true so the reader
doesn't stop for a second
i don't think she would feel that then
you don't want
that you want a sort of seamlessness it
doesn't mean the characters cannot
behave
out of character because it's quite
important that the characters are not
just
bland and easy to read they can be as
complex as you please
but all the time your effort is
to make what they're saying and feeling
and noticing
in some way or other true
or at least possible or at least
not irritating for the reader to say
this is an
author now the issue of the author here
is important the author has to become
invisible
the the self-suppression is supreme the
first thing you do is you say
the page is blank it is not a mirror
i am not looking at myself as i write
i'm looking at something blank i'm
filling the page
it is not me it is the character and
therefore interjecting or seeming to be
present
is is a very dangerous it can be done
but it's dangerous
and i wouldn't try it there are other
people who are very skilled at
but um all the time you're concentrating
on the person on the character you have
made
and how that character responds to
sensations or to experience
what are you looking to do with your
first edit
i think you become your own reader and
the more you read the more
books you normally just read the more
skills you become
at detecting [ __ ] at detecting a
sentence that doesn't work and detecting
something doesn't ring true
or often with me it's detecting when
something is just too long
and as each read at the moment that i
give something each read
i can take out more i work closely with
editors
and i i actually like editors and i
listen to editors
um but mainly at the moment for me it's
a question of cutting
that you just don't need a paragraph and
it takes you a while to realize i just
don't need a paragraph
it's a huge liberation just getting rid
of it and realizing oh my god i've just
freed the book from that boring
paragraph and i've released it into the
upper air
and so yeah that's what i'm that's what
i'm doing
really once the first draft is there and
if a sentence stands out i mean you're
always using repetitions
and it's always a word you use far too
much
i mean i just try to wean myself off as
as
though or as if which is you know
you find this really useful but you've
got it you use it sparingly
and they're always
so someone else can often point this out
to you do you realize how many times
and often the last sentence of a
paragraph isn't needed
that you should let the paragraph just
dangle
rather than try and do it clanging into
a paragraph
there's a lot of stuff like that um it's
quite enjoyable by the way compared to
the initial business of getting the
thing down
the editing is sort of sweet work what's
the quickest you've ever written a book
i wrote brooklyn very
quickly um i probably had it um
done in i would say
15 months maybe from it from its
original
from starting it yeah probably had it
done but
by then and um maybe with the black
water light with both of those books
others others have just been i mean
forever really you know
and something like the henry james novel
the master of
those years you know
it's lovely work and you hope it's never
going to end where do you think your
desire to write comes from i remember
meeting
sue tanzan at a literary conference in
portugal and she just said to me
without any other introduction so what
happened to you
and what she meant was what in childhood
or early adolescence what trauma or what
difficulty occurred in your life
that caused you to to move into this
sort of strange circle of wishing to
create images
um that are disguised or concealed
images of yourself
that manage actually to release quite a
lot of personal energy into the world as
though the world
needs to hear your story over and over
and over
as metaphor as transfigured
notions of the self and that your voice
somehow or other
needs needed to speak up above the
general babble
and i of course said well you know i we
had difficulties at home that my father
was sick when i was a kid and he died
when i was 12 and
she said oh oh yes well that would be
you know
and w jordan said it very beautifully he
said
as much neurosis as the child can take
that if you want to make a writer in a
family you give the child a vast amount
of neurosis
and i think writers make too much of
this you know i think it's something
that
writers love the idea so we're special
because we were all badly damaged and
somehow our damage were taking
it out or we're trying to heal ourselves
using fiction
i don't know i mean i mean i mean it
might be much simpler to say that um
you you suddenly realized aged about 12
or 13 there was something you could do
that other people couldn't do which is
write down things
and make people believe they were true
and that and that is remarkable because
it's it's
i mean it's a thing that children really
love hearing a story
so it's not as though stories are
rarefied or strange or belong
to some literary community but that
whole idea of
what happened next who went where he
went where
why did he go there that all of that
is so basic to our nature and if you
find
that you know in medieval europe or in
in pagan ireland that you know around
the campfire at night
people would listen to you and want you
to appear
so you could tell a story that's pretty
important and so um
maybe it comes from some sort of mixture
of inadequacy
on one side and wanted to be noticed and
on the other side an ability to do it
and therefore it actually um makes up
for a lot of things that are probably
missing in you
but but you're but it is back with the
business of that the people are at night
have nothing to do they're sitting
around and you start
and you tell the story and by the time
the stories end
it's a dawn and they're not frightened
anymore
fantastic thank you so much for more
debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv